make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking back up again
with New Mutants and we're in part 4 now
if you guys recall the previous city
that we did on the New Mutants where you
basically had is you had a armor you
would essentially grab glob and in
maxime and manon and it gone forward for
the purpose of trying to find beacon
angel two other former teammates who
decided not to show up on Kokua and we
ended up learning that Beeks father was
basically dying and the result was that
when armor had brought forth some
medicines that could be used to
basically cure the father of beak that
in turn led to a whole bunch of gunmen
showing up on the doorstep of beaks home
just say like like we didn't really know
what their intention was we just knew
they were just kind of being dicks and
so what we end up learning or a couple
things one the leader of this group
his name is a stimula and second they're
here for the purpose of trying to
acquire more medicines now of course
taking everybody out and really that you
know putting power harnesses around
everyone this basically leads to what's
kind of an interesting bit of a story
but also to be though basically becoming
what he hates and the reason why is
because what this does is it tells us
that on the island of coast of Perdita
which is where team yellows from or at
least to emulate on the rest of this
group are from that their country at
least their land was really the victim
of essentially dumping right like like
dumping hazardous materials by various
corporations and the result was that
what it did is it led to this massive
amount of infection by about rio for
about eighty five hundred people now the
result of this is that there were
various medicines that were available
right like creek hoenn medicines or at
least cures that were being offered by
the government didn't really seem to be
from kokoa and instead of being able to
like give them out freely and saying hey
look here you guys go you know all i
kind of good stuff
instead they were being charged a
thousand bucks a pop and so as a result
of that what it basically did is it led
to this kind of debate or this kind of
discussion or or I guess you know
argument of sorts between the government
and pharmaceutical companies that led to
like more people dying while all this
was going on now the funny thing about
this is that armor chimes in and says
well then just like tell your government
to recognize Rico as a sovereign nation
and Xavier and all them will give you
all the medicines for free right but the
issue with this is that one the guy who
was in charge of the pharmaceutical
company named named Kevin McKinnon has
been killed right assumingly tumulo and
the rest of his guys [ __ ] lee killed us
off now this is an important thing to
understand is it Tim you know does not
directly say that he was the one that
killed a guy
he just says it's been taken care of now
a couple things
keep in mind here is that while this
agreement was being worked out with the
federal government that ultimately the
death toll kept rising right and by the
time an agreement was reached 20,000
people had died and 65,000 were probably
about 45,000 were left infected out of
the 65,000 that had been been infected
in total but the issue is that at the
moment these you know that these
medicines Lisa need for these medicines
in these trying times are still a theme
that's there but the funny thing about
this is that when you end up talking to
or at least when when tumulus talking to
armor you know where she basically again
encounter brings up this point we'll
have Charles Xavier you know have you a
country you know basically side with
Cocola and you'll get free medicines his
response is no I'm not gonna ask them to
do that because if they do there goes my
profit margin so essentially what this
guy is doing is in turn getting medicine
from the government after this deal was
worked out and now he's basically
playing the role of Kevin McKinnon and
it's just kind of like okay so like what
in the heck then like this guy's
basically as bad as the guys that he
just gunned down and it's kind of one of
these things where like this cycle
always repeats itself right you know and
he really kind of makes this point in
saying that where they're suffering
there's an opportunity which is a pretty
terrible philosophy to have to be honest
but at the end of the day what it does
is it switches over to Sage and to end a
boom boom now the funny thing about boom
boom and this might be more of a
controversial point but the funny thing
about boom boom is I don't think she's
really been relevant I don't think
Tabitha Smith has really been a relevant
character since her days on x-factor I
when she had she had a stint on next
wave in the mid 2000 she had some
involvement in the New Mutants different
things like that but she and she
narrowly seemed to achieve the same kind
of relevance she had when she was
brought into the old x4 stories by Rob
Liefeld and so because of that be seeing
her here and playing somewhat of a
significant role or playing somewhat of
an important role it's kind of
interesting but it seems like adverse
and kind of plays on this idea that she
was just kind of free-floating over the
years because she's basically a drunk
right she's just like drinking alcohol
all the time and just kind of partying
and doing their thing and just sort of
having this this you know attitude of
whatever happens happens and so when she
goes to visit sage of course she asked
the question wears armor and all them
and it's been about five days the sages
like well they haven't come back yet I'm
not their babysitter I don't know what
happened to him who knows it's actually
kind of an interesting story because
sage if those you guys were unfamiliar
with her character sage I wouldn't
really say doesn't care about people but
like she's been assigned a role and her
mind in a lot of ways works like a
computer so it's not that she doesn't
really care about any of the other x-men
or anything like that but it's kind of
once you leave the island of kokoa what
you do is on you and it's none of my
business it's none of my concern
you know if it's that important somebody
will sound the alarm and somebody
go out there and look for you wears
exactly what habitus doing that's kind
of the nature of sage readily she's not
really a terrible person she's just kind
of doing her thing and so what ends up
happening here is kind of switching back
to Nebraska to me Lowe tells armor look
like here's what's gonna happen you're
gonna send forces are you gonna send
people who can negotiate right who can
negotiate with Xavier and basically say
fur fur you know if if you want any of
these hostages to live then like you're
gonna give us medicines we want one ton
of medicine for every hostage that we
have which is an outrageous request
right it's kind of a ridiculous request
even for like a situation like this like
no way it's gonna be fulfilled but then
the questions asked my armor how did you
even know we were here in the first
place and this is when ed worsen really
starts to tie into kind of like the
grander picture with what's going on at
dawn of X and there's a few ways of
which he does this the first is my way
of tubular himself right when it came to
the idea that they were going to be
medicines out there provided by cacoa
that could cure virtually any illness
and provide longer lifespans and any
kind of mental illness or anything like
that it was only a matter of time before
what you got were basically the rise of
like petty warlords and strongmen who
are going to try to like usurp control
in a particular region and then dominate
this medical market and decide who gets
it and who doesn't and kind of utilized
that as a means to control that region
at the same time what we also saw with a
rise of these various websites it really
came in two forms the first were those
websites that supported various mutants
who were out there and those websites
who didn't and their web sites out there
who were keeping tabs on where mutants
were going and what they were doing this
is kind of the funny thing
Edwardson almost highs into the old
project wide awake stories right you
know the old fall of mutant things that
we saw during Chris Claremont run you
know we have the picture of Franklin
Richards and it's like do you know where
your child is do you know if your
child's with mutants anything like that
a lot of that fear-mongering you stuff
that went on you know like you need to
be afraid because you know if you're if
you're afraid then you'll do what we
tell you to and so following this what
you do is you pick up with a really cool
scene with Maxime and man and now we
haven't really talked about their
characters before and they're actually
relatively new they appeared in the
extinction of him and the way this
played out is you you kind of had a
long-standing villain and Marvel Comics
named a hub and they had was basically
this guy that had technological
components right he was a cyborg more or
less he doesn't have a huge stint right
like you don't see him all the time you
see him periodically and he does little
things here and there and and so on and
so forth but the idea behind this is
that Maxime and Manon during the during
the extinction event were basically two
mutants who were who manifested their
powers at a younger age and so they were
brought to the Xavier Institute but five
years after that happened they were
kidnapped by a hab and they were taken
to the future
so a hab could basically have them
hounds the overall idea here is that the
hounds of ahab were very similar to the
hounds of like Days of Future past and
so far that during that point in time
where a lot of the guys and the guys
probably asked this right like in Days
of Future past
how does sentinels find humans so far
fine mutants so fast these towns right
hounds were inward mutants who had like
telepathy or empathy or in some form of
fashion were able to locate mutants and
an intern were bred and they were kind
of tortured and their minds were warped
and they were used for the purpose of
tracking down those various mutants the
house of Ahab were very similar to that
but the reason why Maxime and Manon were
so important is because using their
powers together they could dominate and
control the minds of others and turn
them into the hounds that they have
wanted and so that's kind of where their
significance came from now ultimately
once that reality was what's kept from
coming to fruition when Kay will
basically traveled back to stop that
realities exist as to so on and so forth
maxime and Manon ended up travelling
back into the main Marvel Universe and
that's how they end up here but these
characters are really powerful in a
couple different ways and the reason why
is because angel basically tells Andre
one of the guys that are holding them
hostage
you know we my kids can't ingest this
food this way you know I can basically
you know take this food in and then I
can feed it to them much in the same way
that a female bird or I guess a mom bird
would feed you know her her offspring
and then when she and Jets it she spits
out this kind of corrosive acid which
basically disables the the collar of
Maxine who in turn grabs Andre now this
is where the powers come into play and
the reason why is because individually
what they can do is they can tap into
others and they can manipulate their
emotions right they can kind of instill
these little thoughts things like that
and so when she seizes control of Andre
what she says is your cohort you
remember like when you came home and
your cohort was sleeping with your wife
and then he shot all your you know shot
your parents up and killed them kind of
putting these subliminal thoughts these
false false thoughts in the mind of this
guy which in turn leads him to going
insane and then when you have half man
on that jumps in and he kind of does the
same thing then basically all hell
starts to break loose now at that point
like angel in everybody starts to panic
because what you have are these guys you
have one guy who's on the defensive you
have another guy who's basically you
know reliving these false memories and
then they have guns pointed at each
other right so there's an entire
shootout they could go on and anybody
could get caught in the crossfire which
is pretty dangerous now a lot of this
goes into the dangerous nature of Maxine
and men and insofar as because of the
fact that they were kind of twisted and
they were sort of screwed up while some
of those evil elements have been removed
they tend to kind of get caught up in
the moment and they don't think about
the best course of action
so as a result of that what is up
happening here is of course fire ends up
breaking out between these two guys or
at least you know gunfire ends up
breaking out between these two guys and
of course to me it was like what in the
heck is going on at that point there is
an explosion and we're basically met
with the arrival of Tyla the type of the
Smith who used her little plasma bombs
to blow the whole thing up all the while
she's standing there drinking some
whiskey
Tabitha Smith has problems but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explained to miss you guys to
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later Bruce
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]